[Musik]
wonach schmeckt ananas jugend wirklich
wenn es nicht drauf steht marko ja
sebastian deck auf mit welchen tricks
und die lebensmittelindustrie oft
hinters licht führt in düsseldorf wird
sebastian läge in einem einfachen
experiment unsere sinne prüfen mit dem
topseller der milchindustrie dem
fruchtjoghurt will lege die zunge der
marktbesucher auf die probe stellen
ohne das etikett zu sehen soll die
tester die geschmacksrichtung erkennen
[Applaus]
ananas
das schmeckt man ja schon beim hingucken
aber auch wenn es nicht dran steht
[Musik]
ok erstmal ein bisschen an riechen ja
mandarine mandarin ist schon mal ganz
weit weg betonen auch ganz weit weg
dann ist das mango super noch mal falsch
zu sagen banane für sich maracuja nein
auch das nicht - es ist ananas
von 25 testern hat kein einziger den
ananas geschmack erkannt
sebastian lege will beweisen dass dieses
resultat kein zufall ist deshalb
wiederholt er sein experiment im angebot
diesmal mango orange exotik mit
zitrusnoten mango orange alle fälle sehr
lecker hat jetzt aber nicht
ausgeschlossen
aber kann es tatsächlich sein dass die
düsseldorfer ohne den blick auf die
verpackung keinen einzigen frucht
joghurt am geschmack erkennen können
letzter versuch pflaume zimt zumindest
zimt müsste man doch raus schnecken
genau wie ich bin total irritiert wenn
ich das jetzt sage kommen ganz groß an
ihrem gesicht sind wir ohne optische
unterstützung wirklich nicht mal in der
lage so markante früchte wie ananas oder
ein gewürz wie zimt zu erkennen oder
rührt die industrie ein solches einerlei
von aromen mit winzigem fruchtanteil
zusammen dass man ohne bilder und
klingende worte nie darauf käme was das
sein soll
fest steht verpackungsdesign
produktnamen und schicke werbebilder
sind im konkurrenzkampf der
lebensmittelindustrie mindestens genauso
wichtig wie die rezepte kaum vorstellbar
welcher aufwand beispielsweise hinter
diesem bild von einer cola steckt
immer dann wenn es uns anlocken neuer
kunden geht haben menschen wie tim
landsberg ihre finger im spiel
der 48-jährige ist food stylist und seit
20 jahren im geschäft
es dauert stunden sterben als manchmal
ganzen tag für ein foto
kein wunder denn jeder wassertropfen
muss einzeln an seine position getupft
werden
so lange bis alles perfekt ist
wassertropfen suggerieren frischer und
kühler
ich möchte halt lieber auf ein foto ein
schönes kühles getränk sehen wo
tautropfen drauf sind wo ich schon sehr
war das ist eiskalt das wird gleich
meinen durst löschen
für die perfekte illusion kommen noch
fähig eiswürfel aus plastik mit ins glas
sie haben den vorteil dass sie selbst im
heißen scheinwerferlicht nicht schmelzen
jetzt vorsichtig angießen und abwarten
bis er da ist dieser kleine moment in
dem es im sucher genauso aussieht wie
verbraucher sich cola vorstellen
[Musik]
und nun wird es richtig trickreich tim
landsberg zeigt wie man es hinbekommt
das speiseeis auf packungen und plakaten
so wunderbar cremig aussieht
[Musik]
zutat nummer eins ist diesmal kein
imitat sondern echte vanille zumindest
für die optik ist die unersetzlich doch
das war es dann auch mit original
zutaten
denn was gleich wie es aussehen soll ist
in wahrheit eine ungenießbare knetmasse
wieder foodstylist aus wasser und
verschiedenen bindemitteln anrührt das
eis was jeder als ice camp ist
eigentlich gar kein eis wald diese
füllung von der eiskugel die wir so als
war neben das hat eigentlich gar nicht
über die komplette kugel aber wir mögen
so wirklich in dassow und
dementsprechend werde ich alles google
baue die genau diese richtung hat und
man guckt drauf und sagte dass zum 1
für laien grenzt es beinahe an zauberei
wie aus einer hand warmen teig artigen
masse die illusion von eis entsteht
jetzt nur noch die kugeln wie zufällig
übereinander stapeln mit wasser für ein
wenig glanz sorgen und fertig ist das
motiv für den fotografen
kein wunder dass landsberg in der
branche so berühmt ist sein imitat sieht
für die meisten echter aus als das
original
das geht so weit dass die arbeit von
food stylisten bereits unser aller
vorstellung geprägt hat
irgendwie haben sich diese bilden ist
uns bei uns im gedächtnis so eingefräst
dass wir wirklich diese rillen als eis
erkennen und sobald man die hat hat man
das gefühl dass es als letztlich zählt
für lebensmittel hersteller einzig und
allein ob der kunde sich für ihr produkt
entscheidet wenn sich die konkurrenten
im supermarktregal schon kaum noch im
geschmack qualität und preis
unterscheiden dann gewinnen verpackung
und werbung immer mehr an bedeutung
bilder liefern kaufanreize
[Musik]
lasst ihr euch auch manchmal von den
fotos auf fertigprodukten verführen sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über essen wissen
wollt dann abonniert die zdf besser
esser und schauten die nächsten zwei
clips
[Musik]